Ryan's got the legit Shady answer for
every [ __ ] question and hypothetical
we have here hook up a car battery it'll
shock his penis with 24 000 volts I
don't think he'd be peeing again
[Music]
so a man
has been caught on video urinating
on his ex-wife's grave almost every
morning
what the [ __ ] how does somebody know
that if they're not they're almost
everyone the groundskeeper the
groundskeeper goes they needed a 365-day
trial to mention this house
is that illegal they need to [ __ ]
find out if he killed his wife or not
they should investigate yeah this guy
hates his wife's gut this is the best
part dude so he's 68 years old he visits
the ceremony almost every single morning
between 6 14 a.m and 6 18 a.m early
right with his current wife oh [ __ ] and
urinates on his ex-wife's grave damn all
right the current wife got me [ __ ] up
like the willing to go there with him
everybody who support him that's weird
as [ __ ] it's the getaway maybe he wishes
like his ex was that supportive he's
like see how supportive she is she's
down she's a down ass [ __ ] open your
mouth [ __ ] [ __ ] there's pissing on
the grave
that's dedication that's like a four
minute window that he's always hitting
but it's like every morning you got to
wake up [ __ ] put on your coffee and
[ __ ] like that get your clothes on and
stuff like that you know [ __ ] lock
the doors on your way out as you pull
out the trash and then as you're
reversing out of the driveway not to hit
the other people walking drive all the
way to the cemetery every day maybe it's
on the way to the gym you know it's like
they just do it he can't piss before
that stop humanizing them no no well
it's like it's like uh his habit is very
tandem with something that he likes to
do like no I I'll humanize him every
morning he wakes up to just to get
prepared at five goes like this I got
this babe no no he's got morning wood
dude he's rocking fills up his bladder
and his supportive wife is like babe
have some Pedialyte too yeah you need
your electrolife oh no his support I
have some asparagus today here's some
[ __ ] neon vitamins so the man who
discovered B vitamins the man who
discovered this says he can't get his
wife to go out to dinner with him
all the time but this guy gets his wife
to go along with them to desecrate
This Woman's remains every [ __ ]
morning
and by the way this man is the son of
the mom who's being pissed on no
oh [ __ ] also he was like he was like
kind of like Pia he was like private
investigator like trying to be like
what's going on that's why he's watching
that sucks for him so this guy has a
long standing Grudge with the we'll call
him the pisser wait so isn't the pisser
his dad the pisser is I believe his
in-law oh yeah interesting like
stepfather yeah stepfather yeah okay so
because a guy the pi is going to his
mom's grave he's [ __ ] piss on it
every day yeah he's like what he's like
I need to set up some [ __ ] GoPros to
see what the [ __ ] going on okay uh
let's play devil's advocate for a second
please all right what if
yeah [ __ ] group thinking I'm sick of it
yeah you guys are obviously all one
group let me think the other way this
guy and his relationship with his dead
wife yeah ex-wife maybe she [ __ ] had
a fetish she liked to be peed on she
just had a golden shower thing and this
is his way of constantly showing his
love and appreciation she told him every
day for 40 years you better sprinkler me
when I'm gone and he said I will and you
know what there's just exactly there's
just as much possibility of that
weirdness just as much as the
possibility of this weirdness that's all
I gotta say that's very true
there's opportunity for everybody go
ahead group think [ __ ] I think maybe
she had it coming maybe she wasn't that
good of a person and we don't know what
she did to him
and this uh his current wife to allow
such Behavior oh wow that's technically
back in the group think Bowl unlike what
I did but that's cool but you know we're
just playing Devil's Advocate I'm
Devil's Advocate what if the dude is
from a different culture where that's
not an insult it's an insult okay I
think in every culture that's an insult
he has a long-standing grudge with his
ex-wife is that that yeah like my thesis
is not right then do you do you think
it's like if he misses a day like say
the off chance he misses a day do you
think he's like ah [ __ ] I gotta get back
probably OCD I probably wants more
Pedialyte he's like ah [ __ ] I missed it
it doesn't feel right he just respects
holidays like Columbus Day do you think
his his wife he's like he's like you
know we can't go to the Bahamas babe I
know you want to go but we can't go
because we have to piss him so we gotta
piss in our grave you know yeah I gotta
we can't take her grave with us she goes
I understand she's like oh my God that's
so true I forgot about that you're so
dedicated that's really admirable I wish
there was I hope the the tombstone is
next to a tree
it's like he's doing one of these guys
shake it yeah I'm done
real bye what makes me feel good yeah if
you let me ask you this so you know
you're of the type of person maybe you
live in a certain area yeah I'm
honorable maybe no not exactly but your
type of Hope is perhaps you called into
a radio caller you were number nine you
get to go to the [ __ ] Atlantis resort
in the Bahamas for nine days I'm going
so now
you know all you can do is go to an
aquarium store you get the bag where
they put goldfish in you put little pin
Pricks into it you fill it up with your
piss for days and then you just lay it
on your wife's grave and just like
this should last about night it's like
probably nine pounds of piss like that
should come out like yeah
slow drip yeah I'll keep pissing and
even the fish will keep pissing when I'm
gone yeah you are you feeling that way
are you are you like that's at least
getting her the devil is in this
conversation The Devil's Advocate or you
gotta hire like uh like a Moonlight
somebody you gotta hire someone else
like somebody that's really good you
gotta get another study you can hire a
dog walker a [ __ ] reroute the dog's
routes but why would he do this for so
long it's probably that's what we have
to get down the annoying months pillows
all over the place
that's so funny nick I'm so glad you
asked so the man
um has a long-standing grudge with
um the sun oh so it's on him well he
should go piss off so the man was
married to the son's mother
for a short period of time more than 40
years ago and left when she got pregnant
insisting the child was not his okay oh
that's kind of thick testing however
proved the man was indeed the child's
father oh so that is his son but he
doesn't really care and keeps pissing on
the grave what he has had a public
urination charge
um filed against him by the orange Town
Police Department
and um he has not been reached for
comments since and this is in New Jersey
the the son who caught him is his
biological son but he's pissing on her
grave because she said that's not his
biological son he doesn't he doesn't and
they have a DNA test so she's like Dad
can you stop do that I'm not your
[ __ ] Dad it's like Steve Jobs with
Lisa oh with Lisa this is like that's
not my and if you guys remember Steve
Jobs was pissing on all kinds of grapes
dude this guy's a messy boy he's a messy
he's a messy boy yeah this whole
situation is a messy boy routine though
Andy's dedicated he's hydrated that
means Bart hell of respects him because
of the [ __ ] routine that's a nice
dedication is Google heart likes it he
wakes up at 4 30 in the morning pretty
good but it's like I understand this guy
where's the Pedialyte maybe he's a
veteran he's not a veteran okay
I feel really bad for the sun yeah that
means he's the victim here yeah
literally he was [ __ ] in the belly
while they were having their estranged
[ __ ] situation trying to figure out
whose [ __ ] baby was her denying it
was his even though it was his so was
she basically just saying I cheated on
your ass even though that's your baby
and then him being like that's not my
kid so I'm gonna resent him and you for
the rest of my life
and this [ __ ] son had nothing to do
with it except he's [ __ ] finding this
dude his actual father denies being his
father is pissing on his actual mother's
grave every day that's [ __ ]
ridiculous I think if the son that was
watching his biological father peed on
the grave if his biological father was
in his life more he would have gone up
to that guy and just punch him in the
face the first time he caught him
that's what I think you should do
because if you if this is his father's
in his life
okay so he could
he should be face repeated he can't do
that because he's got to record
he's gonna be out he's like somebody
like that [ __ ] I gotta make sure the Red
Dot stays hey no matter what you should
at least Scotch Guard the grave or
something like you're not yeah dude
flexi your mom's getting yeah Flex seals
dude [ __ ] rolling to the next guy's
grave yeah dude like Miracle tape or
whatever Saran wrap it or something pee
pads you know so like bar you could just
lift up the turf put some Saran Wrap
there put the turf back down yeah dude
Flex tape the one where like there's a
big leak and the guy just [ __ ] slaps
it yeah but it also comes in spray form
where you can just like armor anything
you like this guy just needs to watch
late night TV but he's waking up too
early yeah he doesn't have cable this
guy routine or just do that thing where
you uh put like a car battery behind the
stone and it electrifies it so when you
pee it goes
you're wild dude I mean I'm [ __ ]
insane I just like Wayne's World yeah oh
wait no Tommy Boy I like Tommy Boy
remember when [ __ ] He's peeing on the
gym
that's right that means every time
Ryan's in this room and Joe's like you
know what they should do they should
just pee on this guy Ryan's just sitting
there like hey I'm over here internally
[ __ ] myself oh my God that's it
Ryan's got the legit Shady answer for
every [ __ ] question and hypothetical
we have here hook up a car battery it'll
shock his penis with 24 000 volts I
don't think he'd be peeing again
not through that hole instead JK Justice
is like yeah we'll do the same thing
with a [ __ ] guy every time
JK Justice
[Music]
foreign